welcome to mkbhd's impression of the new
twitter or the video that twitter has
put up for it anyway since i don't
actually have it available to me yet
so far to me it looks like someone is
being absolutely surrounded by all
things twitter they might even have a
problem in choosing what to wear that
day they end up going with yes nothing
other than a twitter shirt
then they brush the excess twitter logos
off of their calendar to reveal a big
night on the 14th
and then it appears that they have
visited a grocery store afterwards and
they are still being followed by a
creepy twitter logo
still on the bus more twitter
they even find a record in the record
store with another twitter logo on it
pretty much seems like anything and
everything this person has to do today
has something to do with twitter
now the music gets happier and we
actually find out why this person was
actually in a record store in the first
place to play this record
and none other than more twitter logos
on the ground but we'll avoid them in an
effort to find something that doesn't
have to do with twitter in this person's
day a shot of the night's guy
nope i was wrong he posted this to
twitter too oh but look this is part of
the new twitter layout which takes
excessively large amounts of screen real
estate is a javascript tour and actually
looks a little bit better than the last
version of twitter
by the limited amounts of footage and
experience i have with the new twitter
it looks pretty decent it has a two-page
layout with the standard timeline on the
left-hand side and opening links and
twitpics and hashtags on the right-hand
side
hey look it's that twitter video we just
saw
well to make a long story somewhat less
long no i don't have the new twitter as
of yet but if you follow at twitter
you'll see when the
new twitter actually starts rolling out
and maybe you actually have the new
twitter and you'll be able to show me
more of that in a screencast of your own
until then this is all i've got mkbhd
signing out
peace